at the moment it is looking like the CW  Network are going to pass on Babylon 5.  now there are a couple of reasons for  this firstly Mark pedowitz resigned on  the third of um October just a week ago  he was the president of the CW and one  of jms's closest allies he was always  been a friend of the show and he was  really the driving force behind getting  Babylon 5 back now he's been replaced by  Dennis Miller following next star of  media group's purchase of the CW now he  seems to have been ordered by nextar to  take the CW into a slightly different  direction they're going to be moving  away from a lot of the superhero TV  series we've already seen a lot of them  getting canceled and move more towards  sort of like reality TV and all that  crap that I'm never watching